ça les demandes alors encore garden
party d'halloween dont joue en 1911
cette fois donc il prend du grade et ce
à cologne donc c'était plus à moscou
mais il semble c'était des parties
amicales en fait peut-être de
préparation pour un tournoi et bockel
équine
av affronter un genre très belle oscar
tener je te dire j'avais j'ai entendu
parler de lui mais j'ai regardé un peu
ça va être un joueur plus ou moins dé
100 kw à son époque est donc toujours
est il voit la partie des liquides avec
les blancs e4 une nouvelle fois 5 est
fou c'est 4 au deuxième court donc début
du fou qui convoie dans la partie contre
avant un cahier 3 peut parfois aider à
faire effet quatre d'abord voilà après
dans la pratique moderne on voit surtout
se tordre le cou pour éviter un peu les
betteraves en fait et pendant tout cas
les epci ce que vous en la partie des
trois bons dans les noirs en général
font entre plusieurs options soit faire
glisser six invités blanc je kaliev 3
pour retomber dans une ouverture
italienne soit faire c6 est donc
emprunter un chemin à part pour
éventuellement jouer des 5
et voilà sa dépendance sera par votre
part jaunes italiennes ccc juste un
autre schéma est intéressant ce qui pour
les neuf alors dans la partie tes nerfs
à jouer flou ces cinq cas elle et ses
trois des six est allé keane a envoyé f4
alors ça peut sembler a priori risqué de
jouer à 4 alors qu'elle se fout en face
et éventuellement kg 4 qui arrive mais
semblerait kg 4 soit pas terrible ici
tous ont un peu une faute théorique
parce que f 5 et 5 donc foot le cavalier
de la défense enfin le fou des fonds
plus cavalier bon validé c'est l'art de
faire kaliev 2 vont à noter bien sûr les
noirs pourra défendre avec h5 mais sur
quoi je crois qu'on peut juste faire
cavalier seul et h3 et défendre défendre
makaziwe deux fois
- kf2 et de super gars aussi adam h5
donc menace matin f7 sûrement que le bon
bout c'est g6 et iliad avait acheté si
je sais pas c'est compliqué mais la
vente illustrative qui est sympa à voir
c'est que si petit rock qui a l'air bien
parce que développe le roi et et quoi
d'autres manifs avec sept sapeurs sur le
champ alors la vente qui était donné
c'était qualif 3 crée valère qui avait
l'air pas mal mais j'ai vu encore mieux
donc je vous montre elle en fait s'il
faut g5 darlin si quoi on attaque adam
disons d'un v8 qui a aidé 5
bon ok par-en-bas taxer cette menace
fait des trucs loup manière que je
reprenne le prix d'achat est la vraie
menace c'est celle là qui avait les psys
ce qui est sympa tu comprends vous prend
et juste pas de défense dont l'échec
matin par able à venir donc s'arrêter
pas mal une autre vente qui est bien
aussi se qualifent 3 plus dans l'esprit
de gris qu en fait et prend 1,5 et g5 et
on retrouve le fameux trio de pièces
fouda mme cavalier qui vient tabasser f7
et h7 est
en fait pas grand chose à faire poum
poum poum elle un petit coussin pas fou
g5 qui termine le boulot
l'idée c'est de dévier la dame qui
attaquait et qui doit défendre la caisse
g8 sinon ils dament maths et qui a plus
de casse alors si on prend ça il marié
blâme g8 maths et si on fait plus on
prend balla le prox que vous voir cette
ligne là et après 2 h 50 d'autres comme
ça bon c'est un autre match sympa bon
tout ça pour dire que ouais
éventuellement kg 4 c'est pas forcément
faut pas y aller la fleur au fusil flat
twin avoir analysé avant et le bouquet
ici 6 du coût très logique kf3 de
celui-là fait fou g4 hockey à noter que
dans un blitz je pense tamblyn en 2016
quand gary kasparov avait fait son
retour un peu à saint louis
il est venu caruana là dessus déjà avant
pour alan rapide en c1 mais il avait
pris caruana c'était ça la partie je
peux montrer rapidos quoi bouger 5,6 car
le clouage fois aussi ce bon faut ici on
évite de prendre si ce qui est des
capteurs f1 voilà donc le roi reste au
centre manière peut-être passagère tête
reprend qu'arrivera mais mais mais bon
les pièces blanches se sont un peu à
rapatrier le roi adverse fou ici aidé à
me prendre les jouets le problème je
sais pas s'il avait raté ça ou quoi mais
après kg 6 ballons perdus qualité et ont
moins bien donc c'est une partie de
castor avoue qu'il avait gagné dans mon
cas juana voilà ça c'est une partie
récente en 2016 bref revenons à nos
moutons donc kf3 fuji qui a joué par par
oscar tener qui valait à 4 bon bah il
veut prendre ce fou et
et toute façon là il va le prendre prise
prise prise tout près 9 4 qui avait h 5
flow 3 et l'apparent grave faute des
noirs mastrov de chercher pourquoi ils
ont joué qui allie aux cinq ans son
papier c'est sexy parce que on veut s'en
prendre à sous ou on veut prendre ici
une fois que les pions prend on envoie
d'un match 4 éventuellement donc
pourquoi ça va pas vous pouvez mettre
sur pause chercher sûrement qui s'il
fallait peut-être soir au quai soiffards
comme d'hab cette même si a priori je
trouve que les blancs sont plutôt plutôt
pas mal moi mais bon voilà donc cavalier
alors pourquoi c'est si mauvais et ben
faut se rappeler de le gall cire de le
gall et ça recommence il faut prendre
on a fait un tout nouveau là dessus pour
dire que cloche surinam c'est pas un
clown absolue c'était un terrain et on a
un nouvel exemple faut prendre cette
donc il a monté le roi en deux sets
à noter donc s'ils faisaient fuite il y
avait simplement fou prend ses 5es avec
les noirs allaient être obligés de
rendre la dame par exemple ici est bon
alors plein de bons coups mais ne serait
ce qu on va dire que peu de prise prise
c'est peut-être pas le plus fort mais
voilà on s'en sera qu'une pièce de plus
à la fin donc
voilà donc rôle 7 bat france et 5 quand
même l'échec vous fait monter le roi
petit rock échec alors là il a fait
reprend et le tour la matte fini voilà
c'est c'est ce que comme ça que la
partie est notée après trois et cinq
sacs on disait aussi aux maths en fait
je veux dire fou ici voilà à la je vous
ai pas mis lemattre le plus rapide mais
peut-être le fait compréhensible ces
jeux sont faits des échecs g3 bakaye
points tout ici on voit là et fo h3 et
faut aussi ce et voilà landes refaire 4
5 vous prend vous g4 fou prend et puis
bah ils vont sermat et après après ça le
restera un dernier coup deux derniers
sursauts mot près ce sevrage 4 mais qui
a les f3 seimat
voilà donc nouvelle partie sympa d'aller
keane je pense qu'ensuite on va monter
le niveau aurait pris une vidéo parce
que tant que du coup après les kinés
jouer des tournois internationaux en
l'étranger notamment le en allemagne et
puis il a commencé à montrer de nombreux
joueurs et donc plus de résistance en
face mais on voit le fronton jeu quoi
c'était chaque fois je déjà dit
développement est assez brillant
tactique ouf voilà m'écouter j'espère
que ça vous a plu
on se retrouve bas bientôt pour pour
d'autres vidéos sur a dit qin
qui on va suivre son ascension jusqu'au
de champion du monde la défense du titre
tout ça voilà voilà
allez ciao ciao à bientôt